y aquí tenemos un prisma rectangular es
una figura geométrica en tres
dimensiones formada dibujando un
rectángulo como base poniendo un vértice
afuera y uniendo los vértices del
rectángulo con este vértice exterior lo
que queremos hacer en este vídeo es
entender qué le sucede a este prisma
rectangular cuando le hacemos un corte
vertical déjame contarte a qué me
refiero exactamente
imagínate que este prisma rectangular
está hecho de gelatina o de queso alguna
cosa suave que se pueda cortar pero que
mantenga su consistencia sale ok y ahora
imagínate que tomamos un gran cuchillo y
cortamos por aquí por aquí este prisma
rectangular o sea viene un gran cuchillo
y empieza a bajar y corta justo por aquí
déjame ver si puedo dibujar el cuchillo
a ver aquí voy a extenderla
el filo del cuchillo hasta acá luego por
acá y ahora voy a dibujar líneas hacia
arriba algo así y lo que vamos a hacer
es justo comenzar a bajar este cuchillo
déjame acabar de dibujarlo algo de este
estilo vamos a comenzar a bajar este
cuchillo verticalmente para cortar este
queso vale entonces conforme baja baja
baja baja baja baja va a ir atravesando
el queso y al final se va a caer una
parte del queso y lo que nos interesa es
qué figura queda en el queso es decir
cuál va a ser la figura que queda en el
queso justo en este lado de acá vale y
eso va a ser una figura en dos
dimensiones justo porque el cuchillo es
una figura de dos dimensiones lo podemos
pensar como un plano vale entonces nos
interesa saber cómo se ve la
intersección de esta pirámide con el
cuchillo bueno te recomiendo que te
tengas el vídeo y lo pienses por tu
cuenta unos momentos
bueno vamos a empezar a pensarlo vale
vamos a imaginar que este cuchillo sigue
bajando y bajando y bajando y de este
lado voy a poner otro queso aquí ya lo
tengo preparado
entonces el cuchillo sigue bajando
bajando y bajando y entonces qué sucede
bueno pues al bajar va a salir el
cuchillo en algún momento verdad de
hecho va a salir justo en esta parte de
acá déjame indicarlo de este lado aquí
tenemos que es donde entre el cuchillo
baja baja baja baja baja y por acá y por
acá también es justo donde sale entonces
aquí tenemos el lugar donde sale el
cuchillo déjame dibujar el cuchillo
completamente a ver si me sale
razonablemente bien ahí tenemos este
lado luego tenemos que va para acá esto
baja quizás un poco más
luego tenemos que está por acá del
cuchillo algo así y finalmente queda
algo así muy bien ahí tenemos nuestro
cuchillo que ya atravesó el queso entra
por aquí sale por acá y en los lados en
los lados hace algo de este estilo deja
marcas así entonces qué figura nos queda
bueno pues aquí tenemos los cuatro
vértices y los lados déjame ponerlos con
otro color nos quedarían más o menos así
algo de este estilo si te das cuenta la
figura que queda es un cuadrilátero y de
hecho es un cuadrilátero especial es un
trapecio es un trapecio entonces si esta
figura la pasamos a dos dimensiones se
vería más o menos así tiene dos lados
paralelos este une con este de acá y
este une con este d
muy bien entonces al realizar el corte
de nuestro queso nos queda este trapecio
este trapecio como la intersección del
queso con el cuchillo